si s'il était en face de vous Jamel vous
le diriez quoi Monsieur Debbouze
père euh très bien très très bien et ben
c'est super bien on va faire une
interview mon père ce héros
c'est à dire que là je je jouerai mon
père en fait voilà papa si tu m'excuse
si tu m'écoutes je m'excuse d'avance
comment ça va monsieur debout vous êtes
bien installé là je souhaite très mal
installé c'est très mal organisé
vous voulez boire quelque chose de
Monsieur debout c'est pas la peine merde
[Applaudissements]
c'est la première fois que vous venez à
la télévision
je vous pose des questions bras non non
non non
vous étiez quel genre de père avec Jamel
tu connais Charles Ingalls
c'est pareil
[Applaudissements]
ça vous est arrivé de lever la main sur
lui
la main sur mon fils
j'ai levé le pied le coup de la tête
mais la main toujours le respect à la
main
il a manqué de quoi quand il était petit
Jamel jamais il a rien et il a jamais
manqué de rien bon c'est vrai Louis il
disait que au quatrième il avait pas dit
je suis sûr mais moi je sais qu'il a
jamais été en 4e
[Applaudissements]
vous auriez aimé qu'il fasse quoi comme
métier de Jamel
président du la République suédoise
si c'est possible
ça vous a surpris quand il s'est lancé
dans la comédie je l'avais toujours dit
à mon fils comédienne si pour les [__]
et les homosexuels les deux
ça je sais pas il est là
mais vous avez réagi comment quand vous
avez vu son spectacle monsieur Debbouze
je la veux son spectacle et alors que tu
es votre réaction elle parle de moi
il voit toujours les côtes il voit pas
la mort qu'elle y a derrière
c'est ça qui est dommage
il vous aide aujourd'hui Djamel
non
jamais c'est pour ça je le dis à la
télévision et il est pas sur terre c'est
pour ça j'ai quand même c'est un bon
fils quand même c'est de Bose mais c'est
parce que tu le connais pas
c'est pour ça vous dites ça monsieur je
suis désolé monsieur Drucker moi
toujours
c'est pas
les relations entre deux de vos fils
Djamel et Momo ça se passe comment
les rapports et le sauteries pas
fraternelle
j'ai juste dit à mon fils et Jamel de la
faire travailler avec lui son frère
Mohamed bien sûr mais c'est vrai Mohamed
il a jamais travaillé c'est pour ça
sur son passeport il a marqué piéton
et pourra pas
des combien il faut son frère mais
[Applaudissements]
on compare souvent la famille Debbouze
et la famille pourquoi
parce que c'est vrai je suis un peu
comme joker wingway mon fils Mohamed ça
serait un peu comme gr et ouais et Jamel
c'est un peu comme les [__] pétrole tu
vois
c'est un peu ça
comme vous voyez Jamel avec les plus
grandes stars françaises c'est quoi
Monsieur Debbouze
je suis malade
complètement malade je vois bien qu'elle
glisse dans le show-business j'essaie de
mais j'arrive pas à le quand je le vois
avec
des stars comme avec
l'influence mal dans le je veux pas
j'aime pas s'il était en face de vous
Jamel vous le diriez quoi Monsieur
Debbouze
je sais que tu es milliardaire mais tu
veux pas me le dire
[Applaudissements]
vous vous prenez de l'argent sur ces
cachets non
90%
c'est pas grand chose c'est gentil il y
a des choses qui n'a jamais osé vous
dire Jamel
je t'aime et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu